so immigration is expected to help
alleviate the shortage of skilled
professionals in Germany but mechanisms
such as the blue cart work only under
limited circumstances let's talk about
that now with Holger Schaffer from the
Cologne Institute for economic research
it's good to have you with us we just
watched this report about the Mexican
family in Germany together they seem to
be quite happy about how things played
out for them also thanks to the blue
card but last year the blue card only
attracted some 10,000 foreigners to
Germany that's not really enough to fill
that wide gap that we have here on the
labor market
yeah interestingly Germany has great
difficulties to attract skilled labor
from countries outside the European
Union we have very large inflows from
immigrants from European Union countries
especially Eastern Europe and southern
Europe among them also a lot of people
have a skilled have university degrees
but now that with respect to other
countries we certainly have difficulties
and it is really a difficult question to
answer why is this the case
and although there are many initiatives
and and websites for example make it in
Germany calm doesn't seem quite it
doesn't seem to work doesn't seem to
work it should especially I mean we we
prepared a little graph that shows that
by the end of 2014 some 20,000 blue card
holders lived in Germany and the
interesting thing is that more than half
of them had already been living here
previously because they were attending
university or because they were already
working for a company and that means
that less than 2,000 blue card holders
were new arrivals that seems to indicate
that the blue card scheme is losing
appeal is it to complicate it yeah
perhaps it is a matter of bureaucracy
I think also many people don't know
about the blue card rules that we have
in Germany we have quite the modern and
and adequate immigration law currently
we have as a possibility for people with
a tertiary degree was in university
degree to come to jail
and work here and bring their families
if they have a job that pays 48 thousand
euros per year or in certain
sought-after occupations even 38
thousand euros per year so that's quite
an attractive package I think okay so
teachers are high and but it doesn't
still Germany doesn't seem to be
attracting attractive enough I mean many
Indians for example highly-skilled
Indians they often say that they'd
rather go to the UK or the US where they
can speak the language how big a problem
is the language why I guess it's a big
problem because language is easy entry
into into a society into the labour
market and also to your private life and
German is unfortunately quite difficult
to learn while English is the lingua
franca in our modern day so it's much
easier for Indians but also for many
other people from Africa South Asia to
go to Anglo english-speaking countries
and and just briefly if the blue card
scheme just doesn't solve our problem
what else could how else can we fill the
gap well we have to make it work this
blue card simply as that because there's
a currently large immigration from
European Union countries will eventually
dry out because the major source
countries like Eastern Europe or
southern Europe well have the same
demographic problems that we have or
solve out their current labor market
crisis in the case of Europe there is no
way around it I'll go Shifa thank you
very much for your time